c'est un mot devenu presque quotidiens
depuis près d'un an laïcité
l'anniversaire de la loi du 9 décembre
1905 est inscrit au programme scolaire
une date qui donne lieu chaque année à
des actions éducatives pour faire vivre
la laïcité au sein des écoles ce jeudi
de nombreux professeurs à travers la
france ont donc posé la question à leurs
élèves qu'est ce que la laïcité éléments
de réponse la laïcité c'est pour le
vivre ensemble s'il n'y a pas de laïcité
tout le monde va sont brouillées la
laïcité c'est pour le mélange il y à des
lieux qui sont neutres parce qu'ils sont
laïques comme l'école je ne vais pas
mettre le foulard à l'école parce que
l'école est un lieu neutre et laïque la
laïcité ce n'est pas que la religion on
peut régler d'autres problèmes avec la
laïcité comme par exemple l'égalité
hommes femmes la vérité sort de la
bouche des enfants dit l'adage mais
malheureusement la réalité n'est pas
aussi idyllique l'ifop publié cette
semaine une étude pour le moins
alarmante selon les chiffres avancés par
l'institut de sondage comme vous pouvez
le voir sur ce graphique 40 % des
lycéens déclarent se reconnaître dans
l'affirmation selon laquelle les normes
et règles édictées par votre religion
sont plus importantes que les lois de la
république dans la population française
en général cette statistique n'est que
de 23 % dans le détail 30% des étudiants
catholiques se reconnaissent dans cette
affirmation est jeune musulman la
partage à 65% on peut voir le fossé
entre les cultes qui s'accentue puisque
65% des lycéens musulmans à déclare que
leur religion est la seule vraie
religion là où seuls 27% des jeunes
catholiques la firme on est bien loin
des définitions candide de la laïcité
donné par les élèves de cm2 si vous
pensez qu'on dépens d'angers sur la
laïcité si vous n'êtes pas bien suivi ce
qui se passe dans ce pays depuis
quelques années et mondialement on est
en pleine crise identitaire en pleine
crise des réveils religieux
fondamentalistes en transit entre deux
attentats et donc entre deux attentats
c'est le moment généralement essayez de
faire de la pédagogie pour que la
prochaine génération au moins ne soit
pas ne se fasse pas piéger parmi les
attentats évoqués par caroline fourest
il y a bien entendu l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit il a aussi les chiffres
sont explicites 87 % des lycéens
condamne totalement le meurtrier et son
acte une statistique qui tombe à 75 %
chez les lycéens musulmans 13% d'entre
eux ne condamne pas l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit contre 8% pour l'ensemble
des lycéens alors oui sur le papier ces
chiffres sont inquiétants mais en
réalité il faut se garder d'en tirer des
conclusions trop rapides et ne pas
tomber dans la stigmatisation
en effet cette étude repose sur un
échantillon de 1006 élèves vont 11 % de
musulmans c'est à dire 111 élèves
musulmans sur une population d'environ 1
million en france un échantillon trop
faible pour être vraiment représentatifs
d'autre part le gouvernement a mis en
place depuis plusieurs mois les états
généraux de la laïcité un bilan
trimestriel des signalements aux équipes
valeurs de la république et publiée tous
les trois mois pour la période septembre
novembre
614 cas d'atteinte à la laïcité ont été
répertoriés selon la terminologie du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
614 signalement d' atteinte au principe
de laïcité ont été recensés soit 67 de
plus que lors du dernier bilan d'avril
2021 plusieurs facteurs expliquent cette
augmentation
un retour à un enseignement entièrement
en présentiel une tendance à un
accroissement des signalements depuis
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit l'année
dernière la commémoration de
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit qui a
représenté cette année un événement fort
de recrudescence des signalements
provocations verbales ou contestation de
l'enseignement prodigué en classe les
atteintes sont de formes variées selon
le ministère c'est au collège que ce
produit la majorité de ces atteintes à
la laïcité mais encore une fois ce
chiffre reste très marginal puisque
c'est 614 signalements sont à comparer
avec les douze millions d'élèves
scolarisés en france dans soixante mille
établissements parmi ces atteintes à la
laïcité seule une dizaine est considéré
comme grave par les autorités vous
l'aurez compris tout est une question
d'interprétation restons lucides ils
réclament cité est mise à rude épreuve
en france ces dernières années mais les
constats alarmistes brossé par les
sondages comme celui ci tendent à
renforcer un peu plus un climat
d'angoissé pesant pour les français